else patrick mahomes is due to have toe
surgery on wednesday according to nfl
media he played through the injury since
the divisional round against the browns
rehab several months expected to make a
full recovery look welcome to
professional sports everyone who ever
has an operation
is uh expected to make a full recovery
and already ahead of schedule uh you
know the reality is
and i know he said that he wasn't
bothered by the super bowl of course he
was bothered by it something happened
early in the game to aggravate it as he
was running for his life shireen it was
an issue it was a problem and now he's
getting it fixed just three days after
the game
yeah and he wasn't on the injury report
last week which you know i think maybe
he should have been on the injury report
but even though he was a full
participant all week and he had said
earlier last week it was 100 it's clear
it wasn't 100 the report for me and
rapaport came out before the game that
it wasn't 100 he might need surgery
coming up this week and now he's
certainly going to have that surgery and
i'm sure he'll be fine he will miss out
if there's any on-field work he'll miss
out on that but he'll be ready for
training camp when the chiefs go report
and i'm sure he'll be fine but yeah of
course it affected him you could tell it
affected him he ran for his life and if
that
foot had been fine i think you would
have seen more runs uh by patrick
mahomes in the 33 yards that he had
maybe they had a better chance mike
and sims and i kind of peeled back the
onion a little bit today mahomes was
listed on the injury report as a full
participant as you mentioned and the toe
was disclosed that tells us he was
getting treatment on the toe last week
sims made a great observation they
exercised the privilege of elevating
matt moore from the practice squad to
the roster you can do that pandemic
53-man roster can become 55. two guys
can come up matt moore came up
i think they were concerned that the
flight to tampa could aggravate the toe
could cause swelling could cause a
problem they get to tampa everything's
fine or at least they think it's fine
matt moore wasn't on the active roster
that day so it was just mahomes and chad
henny but they had mahomes
with henny and moore behind him on the
55 55-man roster for a reason and i
think there may have been some concern
and we saw that concern become
manifested early in the game when he was
hobbling around not quite as badly as he
was against the browns but it clearly
was an issue much more so than it was
against the buffalo bills
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports